بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
اما بعد
رياض الصالحين
صلاه
جمعه
last week weed
two narrations
that both offered each other anded each
غسل
جمعه
بخاري مسلم
other
سعيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا جاء احدكم الجمعه فليغتسل
جمعه
[Silence]
صلاه جمعه
جمعه
صلاه الجمعه
ابي سعيد
moreنعم
جمعه
صلاه جمعه question
الجمعه
[Silence]
ابو سعيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم غسل يوم الجمعه واجب
على كل محتلم
جمعه
‏personing
for the day of this is
to person
a person is male or female whether a
person is healthy or sick whether a
person is traveling or a resident
[Silence]
‏Now question
after understanding these two narrations
is what if a person does not bath for
the day
‏affay
when we affay we noting about
of the reward is going to be aff
however we speaking about the validity
of his prayer
is his prayer still going to be valid
without bathing for the day of jum
صلاه جمعه وضو
صلاه
جمعه صلاه
يقول وعن سمره رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من
توضا ض يوم الجمعه
فبها ونعمه
ومن اغتسل فالغسل افضل رواه ابو داوود
والترمذي وقال الترمذي حديث حسن
الله صلى الله عليه مساء
وضو
جمعه
صلاه الجمعه
فبها ونعمه
[Silence]
وضو لا
اذا احدث احدكم فلن يقبل الله صلاه احدكم
اذا احدث حتى يتوضا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
جمعه
وضو
جمعه صلاه
how
there is a reward for any prayer that
person prays
that applies to and outside of and there
is a specific reward
can only be
on
for the of that specific reward
‏sin
and of days
sin in that man et
this re is predic upon a personfing
all the of which are moreing
and making
انء اللهالى
جمعه
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يتقبل منا جميعا نساله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يبارك لنا وعلينا في هذا اليوم المبارك
وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
وجزاكم الله خيرا